make history with Assassin's Creed unity  on xbox one this November announcing the  xbox one exclusive Assassin's Creed  unity bundle join Master Assassin are no  and for the first time unite with your  friends to uncover the hidden forces  behind the French Revolution in an  experience engineered specifically for  today's most powerful gaming systems  plus conquer the Caribbean and the  critically acclaimed assassins creed 4  black flag  don't miss out to Assassin's Creed games  in the xbox one Assassin's Creed unity  get two Assassin's Creed games in the  xbox one Assassin's Creed unity bundle  available this holiday buy xbox one get  assassin's creed unity